it is a pleasure to be here tonight and
to announce
the names of these five wonderful
performances
the nominees for best actress are
angela bassett
in
what's love got to do with it
stockard channing
in six degrees of separation
poly hunter in the piano
emma thompson
in the remains of the day
deborah winger
in shadowlands
and the oscar
goes to
holly hunter
i am so uh overwhelmed to be with that
group of actresses it just slays me
um when i was six years old
i started uh pretending to play the
piano on the windowsills of my bedroom
in the house where i grew up
and um and then after a while my parents
realized that i wasn't going to stop so
they they got me a a cardboard keyboard
to play to see if that might you know i
would get tired of that but i wasn't i
didn't and so then they got me a piano
so for the next 10 years they let me
have piano lessons so i need to thank
eileen parrish my first piano teacher
and i need to thank my parents for
letting me have these lessons
and
jane campion i
i love you i love you
thank you so much for giving me a
character and an experience
that was so difficult to say goodbye to
except that i don't have to say goodbye
to it because
everybody is everybody's now and that is
such a gift
um and michael nyman
who really gave me a veritable
uh
instruction manual
for a way into
ada mcgrath by giving the music
giving me the music that that he gave me
and the entire movie
to experience
and jan chapman
our producer for being so luminous and
for giving the piano and all of us a
place to flourish
harvey and bob weinstein
you also break my heart with your
uncensored passion
and support for this movie
and just thank you all so much for
letting this movie in
and
thanks